- What's up vlog, this is
super exciting interview
for me being a Jersey boy
growing up in the 90s,
hip-hop era,
Redman,
the icon,
the legend comes through,
really interesting conversation
that I think actually
maps to a ton of executives
who've had success,
a ton of entrepreneurs who've had success,
a ton of you who won in your profession
with a little bit of,
what do you do when being
contemporary could be
slightly different than
what got you there,
and so I'm super excited
about this meeting.
I really think it's gonna
bring a ton of value
to a lot of you,
so check it, let me know what you think.
(upbeat music)
I'm glad we connected, man.
- Absolutely.
- [Gary] Thanks for all the love.
- Yeah, yeah, absolute, thanks
for the inspiration, brother.
- Man, that means a lot
to be coming from you,
I'm 42 and from Jersey,
I got real love for you, man.
Especially when you hit
me up the other day,
like to be real quick,
I'm so..
Boyd knows this, you know this,
I'm always focused on
how I can bring value.
It's just my default
because I think that's where
the leverage is.
- [Redman] Mhhm.
- Especially because if I never
have to cash in those chips
then I'm a legend, right?
- [Redman] That's right.
- But there was just
something about our exchange
the other day which is why
I wanted to get this in
real quick.
Just want to get to know you guys but
most importantly or you
may be able to help,
Boyd maybe you'll be able to help,
but I'm like super
intrigued on how I can help.
- Good.
- I want to know what
the fuck you are up to,
what's going on like how
you're thinking about
shit but I'm interested.
I'll help.
- [Redman] Okay.
- But look I think um..
I look at the work that
DJ Khaled was doing on
SnapChat and years ago I was like Red,
he's the character,
he's the guy who has to be chasing
that attention and
getting to the new spots
before everyone else
- [Gary] 100%.
- He's such a brand
and such a personality.
- [Gary] Such a personality.
- You were made for social
and you were made for
being out there.
- He was made for culture and
whenever the spotlights on 1997 MTV,
BET then it's going to work,
and when the spotlights not on,
it won't because if you don't...
Anytime people know like Seal,
it won't work every time.
- [Redman] Absolutely.
- Like talent and charisma
and magic isn't teachable.
The only time magic and
charisma and talent aren't
winning is when there's
not distribution behind it.
The end.
That's why what I'm up to is so powerful.
Once I finish building this machine,
I'm bulding the Death Star.
Literally the Death Star of communication
and then you just point it.
When I say I can help,
I'm interested in helping
to point it at you.
Because it will,
(finger snaps)
and when I say this
it can take 14 months but its like
as long as you do the push ups and drink
the raw egg you'll win that fight.
It's about staying disciplined that's all.
And then what else,
you'll like this,
it's just reverse engineering you,
I think people of our generation,
its not like people their generation where
its like part of their body.
I have a lot of empathy for people that
especially if you're
a celebrity before it,
all those rules are broken,
it's the reverse and so
it's about creating an infrastructure that
allows you to produce the amount of
content you need to produce.
Let's talk about it like family,
what the fuck do you want to happen?
- [Redman] Well first of all
- How much is art
and happiness?
How much is financial?
To me when you're figuring
out the next thing
you just break it down to cut
unemotional columns right?
There's money,
and then there's creative happiness,
those are two buckets.
And then you just kind of like roll,
which one needs to be scratched,
by the way always both
when it's best, right?
- [Redman] Absolutely.
- And then just getting to know you.
Is that around fashion
is that around music
is that around funny clips,
I mean you have a lot of flexibility.
- I think it's also good
context to know that
Doc also owns a clothing
store a skateboard shop.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
I'm aware.
- That's something we've
spoken a lot about,
how to leverage his brand
and how to leverage...
- So what would you like to happen Red?
- First I would like to take advantage of
my platform that I have of being Redman,
my brand.
I think through the years,
my manager and me and Meth as well
we kept our brand up to a level where we
are highly respected and it's
not tainted with a lot of BS.
So I want to take advantage of that
- [Gary] Cash in some of those chips.
- Absolutely.
On these media platforms,
make sure that I'm generating
the right funds and
getting what's worth out of
being on the social media
and then exploiting my creativity
as far clips,
movies.
- [Gary] You have so much man.
Yes it's a lot I can do.
- Boyd what do you think man?
- I mean the store and
the platform that you
were just talking about
sounds like a great,
like Facebook Live,
Instagram Live like branding.
- What do you think
musically because I don't
need to hear that from you.
(laughs loudly)
I'm just harassing you but just your
perspective on keeping it real but
what's your curiosity of it?
How do you think...
Actually before I ask you,
I apologize,
where are you with music,
menatally?
- Oh I'm mentally, I'm 100%
- [Gary] Meaning you
want to produce projects?
- Absolutely.
- [Gary] Where are you contractually?
You a free agent?
- Yes free agent absolutely.
You got obligations?
What's the last thing you did?
- My last album I put out
was on INgrooves Distribution
out there in California its the test and
I'm doing a new album Muddy Waters 2
and I'm putting that out
through INgrooves as well
Distribution.
- If this started a real relationship
that we were really like helping you
like family stuff,
would you wait,
can you wait?
- [Redman] Yes of course.
- I'm thinking about...
It's the best feeling isn't it?
- [Redman] Sure is.
- Okay what do you think,
for real?
To make this a real meeting,
this is the right time for everybody to be
real truthful because
I really have a lot of
intent to help.
I'm so fucking busy.
- [Redman] Yes of course.
- I want to deal in
straight truths because then
I know what to do.
If I start feeling like
I'm trying to figure out
exactly what then I'm dead
because I'm just to...
See what I mean.
What I mean by that is,
do you really want to this?
What do you really want to do?
Where is it?
I'm curious,
for example,
you're such a real fucking legend
back to how this shit all works out
there's a ton of 17 19 year olds that are
really meaningful in
the music game who don't
know you are because
that's just how life works.
- [Redman] That's right.
- We all know that.
But if you actually decide to like,
what I don't have a sense of,
because I don't know and
that's why I'm asking,
and I'll get back to you,
I apologize.
- [Redman] No problem.
- Is where your line
is between you wanting
Muddy Waters 2 to be really successful and
what are the lines in
the sand artistically
that can't be crossed
to make it successful?
And the cool part with me is,
I don't care,
I just want to know.
Let me explain.
Might think you should have five to six
meaningful collaborations on that album
and siphon the pulse of what's emerging
but you might say,
I don't want to fuck with Lil Zan,
like I'm not putting 21 Savage on this.
I don't know that but once I understand it
and understand where...
I'm not going to make you move your lines.
I just want to know what the lines are
and then I want to fill it with the shit
that I know creates magic.
- [Redman] Makes sense.
- You understand?
- [Redman] I just think there's a lot of
opportunities on the table.
- Right, you need to make some music Doc.
The music that...
Not the music that people expect.
Only good's going to happen.
Lil' Wayne made a fucking rock album.
He's okay.
If the first thing you do is a
fucking piece of shit song straight up
by the market
you wouldn't put it
out if you didn't think
it was good,
but let's say it doesn't work.
It's going to do nothing
to your fucking status.
Michael Jordan played for the Wizards.
But my intuition is,
you do it four times,
17 year olds in Oklahoma
City are going to be like,
you my new favorite artist is Redman.
That's what I think.
I know with every ounce of my soul.
You do that,
let me give you a little secret,
the skateboard shop,
the clothing brand,
the following count on Instagram
it all starts changing.
Khaled and SnapChat is a
once in a decade thing.
You putting out a song that gets hot,
that's a foregone conclusion.
You just need to get
the fuck out of the jail
that everybody put you in.
- Sensitive ass audience I got.
(laughs)
- Guess what, they love
you and you love them.
- [Redman] That's right.
- Guess what,
I got shit on for not
being the wine guy anymore
when I started talking about business,
until I didn't.
Leave your two cents below,
make sure you subscribe to the channel,
what's your thoughts on Redman,
what's your thoughts on my
performance in this meeting.
(upbeat music)